comment ça s'est passé votre première
rencontre nadal alors plonger dans les
souvenirs dans le monde des films qu'on
a fait ensemble c'est gwen à gaza
grangier qu'ils lui ses grands j'ai
combien de temps il ya plus de 15 ans
tout cas ça oui tiens et à ce moment là
j'en avais déjà fait lui tous ses films
un pas important et moi j'étais vraiment
un débutant parce qu'elle fait du film
est une belle
j'ai fait des petits films policiers des
petites choses comme ça et j'avais ce
qu'un film bat mazères film eyes
nouvelle gt gt vraiment un auteur
débutant gens lui avaient des atouts
sont tous sont 20 s j'ai mangé mon
volume a été fait tout est filmé de
carnets toutes les manières et ses
granges et qui nous a mis en contact
parce que les grands j étais pote avec
duran avait des le connaissez bien
venise a fait très froid chez nous deux
il connaissait et moi j'avais travaillé
avec ranger fruits dans votre âge ou
l'autre d'entre les louer
comment ça s'est accroché j'ai bien
accroché aux étrangers voulaient que je
fasse un film il ya ben c'est pas une
île et il m'a toujours dit
et ça y est besoin de le dire d'ailleurs
scellé qui mettait là ils m'ont venu
tout seul depuis un certain temps mais
tu sais faut aller les vedettes comme on
dit il faut aborder faut une occasion
des rencontres à fond info alta de
turquie si comme opportune je pense que
tu as trouvé dans les dialogues
d'audiard un langage qui tu allais très
bien enfin que tu parles est
naturellement oui mais tu comprends
c'est pas parce qu'il est là et me james
woods lui il a du talent qui compense
non pas parce qu'il est parce qu il
écrit comme ça parce que avec lui j'ai
quand même fait les grandes familles de
président fin des films de bourgoin il
n'y a pas du tout le pré où il ya pas
non bio ça ça c'est un marché oui il
faut dire que jean a toujours réussi un
lien à bleu mandia la liste parce
qu'enfin faux souvenirs il ya eu ce
pacte qui avait défié durant la grande
illusion
vraiment il ya eu ensuite jenson et pépé
a quand même été un film important
surtout sur le plan du dialoguiste et
puis ensuite eu l'époque pré vert donc
on peut dire que jean a tout réussi à
ces diables
moi j'en parle pas ça m'a réussi alors
ça fait démarrer on a l'impression d'un
d'une idylle parfaite vous êtes en train
de roucouler tous les deux sur vote des
langues le dtm des graines en douce
alors je pèserai sera exempt linden ces
maîtres il met dans les papiers en plus
de temps à mardi mon fils est il est un
petit peu prendra juge ma faim vous avez
eu comme dans toutes les liaisons en
quads étaient des petits lyon où il est
bon ainsi que jean oui c'est le pari non
non non à la porte m chapron elle va
porter le chapeau mais révise d'une
poignée de flotte il arrive toujours à
se tirer du truc
il est réputé pour avoir mauvais
caractère les tout le monde le sait car
là je passe doit à mon directeur ce qui
n'est pas vrai au fond là tous les deux
un petit peu
tu vois produit avait mauvais caractère
qui a fait ça je perds tout le monde
même la remettre à lui enlever ses
jambes le coup deux de mauvais caractère
j'ai du caractère c'est tout qu'est ce
qui est terrible dans la vie j'ai
beaucoup de choses mais tu sais moi je
suis révolté naturel tu as révolte et
naturel les contestataires maintenant
ils n'ont rien inventé moi j'ai toujours
été contestataires et par exemple il ya
un truc que je trompe rampant par
exemple depuis que j'ai l'âge de raison
qu'ils comprendront les républiques les
machins et où tu as voté et balayez gars
qui continuent à voter tant que ça peut
et chaque coup c'est pareil
moi je vois tu pas moins aux deux points
je subis alors qu'est ce qui t'intéresse
dans la vie au contraire ce qui
m'intéresse il ya beaucoup de choses
aussi dit motors par exemple qu'est ce
que tu fais dans une journée rien quand
tu quand même pas rien rien rien rien tu
sais y'a des gars qui disent je lis
beaucoup et moi je lis port tu comprends
le g pour tarbes et des bouquets achète
wafers j'ai vu des bouquets à c'est toi
oui bon je sais ma femme qui vit pour
moi elle ça ça fait partie de 16 go si
tu fais aussi tu veux toujours dire que
tu ne lis pas et ça c'est un réglage
andy tu disais pas moi j'étais pris en
flagrant délit en tout cas d'avoir lu
parce que il était arrivé de moins
prendre island pour un livre que nous
connaissons bien tous les deux pour le
voyage au bout de la nuit
oui je croyais connaître barker un jour
je te dis sais plus quelle phrase et bah
moi j'avais ariane et tu m'as coupet tu
m'as dit non ça commence pas comme ça ça
commence par c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé comme ça comme un délit
- nettoyage et au delà mais de suite sur
simenon talent une certaine quantité de
signes d'entre nous aimeraient beaucoup
d sion bâle avait déjà deux grands
auteurs de la les auteurs très important
pour moi en tout cas que tu connais fort
bien quand donc tu ne lis pas que marie
thérèse com c'est vrai que la légende de
ça fait plaisir pour des satellites bas
non non non non non non
jeudi paris 10 paris tueur parce que je
m'intéresse au four et mafata les autres
choses over j'aime bien par exemple
intéressant pour moi c'est un léger
c'est tout à fait autre chose je vous
dis qu'on peut pour moi pour moi il ya
des gens des gens et qui sait que ça
n'amuse pas et ça ne plaît pas mais moi
tu commences il réellement un n'avons
jamais levé je te dis c'est pas si on
sait qu'elle sentait cover mes couleurs
et j'étais curieux de course l'an passé
avait la terre vous intégrer au cours à
moi j'ai des couleurs classiques et
jaune comme mauvais dans le temps leur
ai dit boutons d'or
topi la voix si c'était joli j'allais le
maintenant qu'on peut plus à maintenir
leurs politiques avec boutons d'or de
pilotes c'est joli non mais tu m'avais
dit assez longtemps de ça d'ailleurs il
faut parler des courses comme ça tu
manita vu un peu des chevaux de course
parce que ça a fait plaisir à ton père
de voir passer des couleurs c'est vrai
ce qui m'ennuie c'est que je pourrai pas
lui donner le prix de diane heures alors
maman qui voit çà de là au moins parce
que lui pour lui le le prix de diane
c'était le
le plus beau prix du fer chantilly avec
les femmes habillés tous à l'art
j'aurais voulu lui gagné le prix de
galles mais ça mon vieux j'y voyais
aussi des contradictions parce que comme
toi regarde vagal de vote contre un
descendant direct air donc tu as fait de
ne pas aimer le cinéma tu as fait 100
films d'enfants absents n'ont pas non
plus jamais lits dont jamais dit que
j'avais pour le cinéma je dois tout au
cinéma oui j'ai jamais et que j'avais
sans examen avec ce sont les à côté du
cinéma souvent qu'ils sont quand même la
durée je fais un métier de saltimbanque
qui fait ça c'est l'échec cela des
saltimbanques du voyage ce qui te
concerne un peu fort mois passé ton
point de vue mais ça mais bon dieu que
tu le veuilles ou pont nous restons des
saltimbanques de même figé il m'a dit
encore tout à l'heure on fait un métier
ne manquera pas d'en essayer maintenant
essayez vous auprès des pouvoirs publics
elles ont essayé auprès des visas ils
vont couper les ballons essayez vous
voyez pouvoirs publics d'aller réclamer
quelque chose pour les acteurs pour les
pour les auteurs pour les trucs on le
prend pour un poids de près le touquet
on me prend pour un plaisantin on dit
comme avec tout le pognon vous gagner
car ils croient qu'on va énormément de
produits est allé tout gérer tout celui
qu'on leur donne alors certes un petit
peu tes défauts qu'est-ce que nabil al
jean les cheveux on va à confesse toi
peur je suis bourré de défauts je mets
tu vas gens rien quand même encore une
fois ses contradictions et romaine la
toison d'or il aime finalement le cinéma
puisque il le fait d'ailleurs quand on
fait bien truc je le sais on sait qu'on
aime ça dans son image le cerf j'ai
toujours dit que je servais il fait
envahir et icône et céline barker est
bien de savoir faire il est anti
militariste l'idée de cela hier en pente
m'aviez pas une premier coup de clermont
qui s'est engagée
alors moi jupons également touchés
c'était en 2009
entre anthony n'en ont pas mais enfin
après dans les forces
bah oui parce que je croyais un théâtre
et machina coin je croyais qu'il fallait
que je croyais qu'il fallait erreur
alors ton talon d'achille a tu nous a
pas dit ce que qu'est-ce que tu qu'elle
sentait dé folle et je te dis j'en suis
poète et vos oreilles
je suis pourri budget ritualité
consultant la fidélité oui ça sert elle
l'argile as well well well cherchari pas
toujours journal celle là tu as tout
avec quelques avec tout le monde a
failli ta famille avec tes copains les
tuer tj pourquoi pour lui donc c'est
peut-être pour ça que tu peux te payer
le luxe d elle qu est-ce que quelqu'un
tout de même les réunions de copains
avec un bouquin merlot à lille de projet
relais fillon se tait sale et un petit
peu comme ça oui oui abattue sur londres
et vie dure nous l'avait laissée à elle
même on l'a eue descendez sévère avec
lui le lino oui le lino legrand vielles
moi il ya une frontière de temps en
temps paul selon m
et là ça part sur le vélo assez
facilement mais c'est chad wade wierre
qui fait sur les femmes de prendre non
pas tellement par huawei à bout parce
que 10 dont chacun et good que t'as qu'à
te prouver avec lino assez du sahara
avec lino c'est du sérieux
tu sais le truc de dingue esbly à
bernard aussi d'oublier bernard
sérieux et là vous êtes un transit un là
vous êtes attendus sur la beaufort
l'avre lui mange pas beaucoup changer la
vie
il mange pas beaucoup avec mellino alors
tu parles un quadrille de moche ou r1
ils nous rendent double aussi ça tout ça
parce que je me souviens - la maison à
la maison quand je me rappelle un petit
salé aux lentilles une fois et d'un
cuisson 2 sans oublier une autre fois
mon vieux tu crois et qui va être une
tuerie qui va tout et lino quand tu
manges tu voir et qui va être plutôt
plus parler dans les boîtes noires qui
font flap clac clac clac vous dis merci
je m'approche et même but et si tu veux
pas savoir ce que lui champion du montre
et